[Music]
[Music]
good evening my name is Erica and as
president of the MIT Western Hemisphere
project I would like to welcome every
each and every one of you for coming to
tonight's event entitled the uses of
Haiti what I would like to briefly
discuss with you right now is just to
mention that this event was co-sponsored
by the MIT Western Hemisphere project
MIT student Pugwash and the mi t--'s
technology and culture forum as you can
see up here on the board there's three
coming events to our tomorrow one is an
evening of Latin American chamber music
and a Pugwash student conference
entitled technology in the new global
context rethinking social responsibility
I encourage people to attend those
events and the western hemisphere
project will be open having an open
meeting within the next two weeks
okay briefly to discuss I'd like to
mention that our schedule for this
evening is as follows first the I'll
give introductions introduced Nancy
Dawsonville we'll introduce our two
speakers this evening dr. Paul Farmer
and professors Noam Chomsky professor
Chomsky will speak for a roughly half an
hour and professor farmer will speak for
a roughly half an hour and will be
followed by questions and I like to
begin with an introduction as a research
fellow at the Harvard Center for
population and development studies Nancy
Doran Phil's work focuses on health and
social justice issues within the Haitian
Devorah as a social anthropologist with
the specialization in migration studies
she lectures on women's health and
violence at the Harvard School of Public
Health
her research also includes domestic
violence as a public health concern
among Haitian women she's presented her
work at a wide range of academic and
international conferences most recently
at the UN conference against racism in
Durban on the intersection of migration
xenophobia and violence against women
she is a member of Partners in Health an
advisor to women's program at the UN
Academy and an affiliate at the Harvard
program in international analysis and
conflict resolution currently she was a
faculty advisor for the Harvard Haitian
Students Alliance and now with great
pleasure I would like to present to you
Nancy Dawsonville
good evening everyone I'm very happy to
be here and I thank you for being here
to join us in hearing and learning and
expressing concerns about the present
conditions in our beloved Haiti there
are two people here with us this evening
don't need much introduction dr. farmer
as you know has been working in Haiti
for the past 20 years in infectious
disease but fundamentally addressing
issues of the poor from a systemic
standpoint from a spiritual standpoint
and from an economic development
standpoint his work is very much rooted
in the actualization and the empowerment
of the more marginalized people in Haiti
of which our population has the highest
percentage so I take this opportunity to
thank him for a lifetime of dedication
to my countrymen and particularly the
most disadvantaged of my countrymen I
then would like to attempt to introduce
professor Chomsky who has written
extensively on a number of issues but
particularly our focus this evening is
the impact of American or US Foreign
Relations on the current situation in
Haiti namely the economic embargo
I just want to contextualize our
discussion this evening with with some
remarks and I would like to start by
echoing something that dr. farmer has
said consistently in his writing and his
well attended lectures on the other side
of the river that what's happening today
in Haiti the economic embargo is the
result of a series of historical
antecedents that cannot be taken out of
the equation if we are to really look
what the circumstances are in addition
to that I think it's it's important to
understand as Professor Chomsky has also
said repeatedly in his writings that
democracy is a process and the outcome
of democracy requires a series of
fundamental conditions namely that the
sovereignty of the people has to be
respected the agency of people in making
certain choices about the kind of
governance that they have how that
governance will be applied and who they
will answer to has to be part of their
agency and has to be part of their
choice I think on the eve of our
Bicentennial independence the question
for me is what does it mean that today
we are under economic embargo what does
it mean that as the I mean everybody
calls us the poorest country in the
hemisphere and a lot of people have
contentions about that where I would
rather say we are the most impoverished
country in the hemisphere because it has
happened systematically with very
deliberate intentional policies that
have led to the impoverishment of Haiti
one of the things that that's very
topical today people talk about
reparation well not only were we the
first country to be under embargo when
we became independent which that too was
a process but the embargo allowed the US
and its allies not to recognize our
sovereignty for about 60 years and yet
during that time selectively there were
trade agreements that benefit
the countries of the north while
beginning what we see today as the most
impoverished nation in the hemisphere a
lot of prerequisites have been put on
why we haven't gotten the 500 million
dollars in loans and grants that were
approved a lot of it has been relegated
to allegedly problems with elections
well I think the other oldest Republic
in the Americas also understands what it
means to have problems with elections
the other issue that's been put forward
is that our cabinet was not pluralistic
enough and in the name of democracy and
in the name of diversity in in our
cabinet it was important to change
certain senators every time they came up
with a different prerequisite which we
fulfilled as a sovereign state something
else came up so I've thought about this
a great deal and I thought you know this
is becoming like a kaleidoscope of
democracy and the colors are changing
the shapes are changing the demands are
changing and we're not getting a fixed
picture from the powers of the north as
to what it is that they want in order to
release the funds which are hampering
any humanitarian endeavors any
humanitarian initiatives and any real
fundamental systems and building blocks
for the democracy that we fought for
from the very beginning 2004 is just
around the corner and our struggle for
democracy began way back 200 years ago
and we have had a fixed picture about
what democracy means we still have a
fixed picture the people of Haiti have
spoken
we have heeded
the prerequisites of the changing shapes
of the changing demands and now in the
name of democracy with big D in the name
of humanitarian concerns which seems to
be the epitaph for everything that's
being done today in the world we demand
the release of these funds thank you
[Applause]
so now professor Chomsky is going to
talk to us and share his thoughts about
the implications of American foreign
policy on the economic embargo imposed
on our country today
[Applause]
glad to learn what I'm supposed to talk
about that's fine well anything I'll do
I understand well let me lead in from
the last talk I gave which was last
night in New York where I had to be
taken out under police protection you
can guess what the topic was it was
about the Middle East tonight if
anything controversial comes up I'm
gonna hand it over to Paul so well
worried about the Middle East the maybe
just so I can have some continuity a
very short word you may have seen kind
of an interesting article in The New
York Times magazine a couple of weeks
ago by Deborah Sontag on the
Palestinians in actually made a good
point she says she was talking about the
difficulties of discourse between
Palestinians and the West and why it
never seems to work and the one the
problem that she pointed to is quite
real she said the Palestinians keep
harping on history where history means
anything that happened more than about
five minutes ago and the West doesn't
want to waste time on all this sort of
old-fashioned boring nonsense but just
get on so that the West can lead the way
to a glorious future and that makes this
course really hard and actually that
point generalizes all over the world
those who have their boot on somebody's
neck never want to know how it got that
way that's boring old-fashioned dusty
old stuff let's just go on with our boot
on the neck and make it even better but
the ones who have their neck under the
boot they somehow have a different view
of things because there
and uncivilized them you know that sort
of savage you know well I was asked to
say a couple of words about the
background including the history meaning
what happened more than five minutes ago
which puts me on the side of the victim
so that's good on happy to take that
position that's position we ought to
take no not necessary to say the as far
as democracy is concerned I think it's
very clear why Haiti doesn't meet the
standards of democracy the same reason
that didn't meet the standards ten years
ago when it had its first democratic
election the election just came out the
wrong way the election was the US had
with certain confident that the election
would be won by its candidate World Bank
official who would lead the country to
you know on to this brand-new year of
neoliberalism that had already had a
certain history in Haiti
he got 14% of the vote and out of the
woodwork came a populist priest who got
two-thirds of the vote without any funds
or any publicity or anything else
because things had been going on in the
country that nobody paid any attention
to they were in the slums or in you know
in the hills and places where no real
people live but they had organized you
know a vibrant democratic society maybe
the most democratic society and the
hemisphere maybe in the world but on
their own you know without control from
above and that doesn't fly you know
that's not democracy it's not for us or
anyone else and furthermore this is
pretty official so instead of quoting
myself I'll quote a real expert Thomas
Carruthers is the best known scholar of
on issues of latinum of the emerging
democracies in Latin America is written
the standard work and he writes from an
insider's perspective he was part of the
Reagan State Department involved in what
they call democracy enhancement
so when he writes on the effect you know
bringing democracy to Latin America
rights from both as a scholar and as an
insider and he's pretty honest about it
he says that the Reagan policies were
very sincere but they failed and they
failed in a curious way they said in the
areas where US influence was least
namely in the Southern Cone of Latin
America there were real steps towards
democracy which the Reagan
administration tried to prevent but
wasn't able to prevent they sort of
happened anyway in the areas closer
where the United States has much more
influence and control infected basically
run it for a century or more the
policies still were sincere but they
just didn't work and the reason was that
the United States he says wanted
top-down democracy in which the
traditional ruling elites remain who
have been associated with the United
States remain in power but under
democratic forms and in a sense that was
achieved but you know as an honest
person he thinks that's not real
democracy but but he's correct that's
exactly what the United States wants and
you'd expect any powerful state to want
some kind of formal democracy because it
sort of looks good and but top-down
forms in which traditional elites those
who have concentrated wealth and power
in their hands because of their
alliances with the boss in the West us
in this case they have to remain in
power and certainly the same picture is
held for the United States itself and or
always has been back to the
Constitutional Convention so that's the
picture for us and it's got to be the
picture for everyone else there's even a
technical name for it in the academic
literature it's called polyarchy so
theorists of democracy
argue that we ought to have polyarchy
not democracy polyarchy means small
groups of elites what James Madison
called the wealth of the nation the the
the wise section those who have sympathy
with property and its rights they ought
to rule the rest ought to be
factionalized they are allowed to
participate because it's a democracy but
periodically they participate by every
once in a while coming out and picking a
lending their weight to one another of
the responsible men who represent the
the wealth of the nation those who have
the interests of property at heart
that's the way this country is supposed
to run that's the way every country's
supposed to run and that means if a
populist priest comes out of the
woodwork with two-thirds of the vote
without any money or any publicity just
basing himself on grassroots
organizations that aren't supposed to
exist that's not the right kind of
democracy so of course it has to be
stopped and that standard the Haiti
still still hadn't they're kind of
backward and uncivilized and haven't
figured this out yet but though the
United States has been trying to teach
it to them for a long time well I'm say
a few words about history or those of
you who've taken a history course in
junior high school will remember that
half a millennium ago a group of savage
barbarians and the west of Europe
launched an assault on the rest of the
world and I've practically devastated it
ever since one of the first places they
came to as in fact Haiti which where
they were over awed by what they found
by the they regarded it as the Spanish
this is Columbus las casas the great
contemporary historian described it as
the most densely populated part of the
world which could have been true and
they were overwhelmed by the wealth and
the the peaceful population and they
in people or so and they just couldn't
believe it
well the current Haitians can't remember
what happened to their ancestor to the
original to those who Columbus found
because they were wiped out within about
25 years or so I just were no good as
slaves and so on and they brought in
African slaves too to be able to extract
the wealth of the country and send it
back where it belongs namely to the
savages in Western Europe and it did
Haiti was the richest colony of the
world the perhaps it was only the only
comparable one also discovered so-called
pretty early was bangle bangle which the
British when the English came they were
also astonished at its wealth and
advanced industry and so on and it's
maybe an oddity that the two symbols
very symbols of disaster and
impoverishment today are Haiti and
Bangladesh that is the two richest areas
maybe the two richest areas of the world
and the longest under Western rule and I
see that generalization kind of extends
to the Western Hemisphere itself in the
20th century Haiti has been the leading
beneficiary of US intervention all kinds
military military occupation you know a
experimental program scientific
approaches to how to do things and oddly
it's the most impoverished country in
the hemisphere there are two countries
that vie for second place every year
they shift a little of their Guatemala
and Nicaragua which by accident happened
to be the second major targets of US
intervention in the hemisphere that's
another one of these odd accidents like
you know the fate of Bengal and Haiti
over centuries that you would only know
about if you took a real course in
history then it would be taught in
junior high school and the implications
of it and it goes on from there
that's not the only only example Haiti
did I hate he was was incredibly rich it
was producing about three-quarters of
the sugar in the world and all sorts of
things but producing it for the
conquerors it a large part of the
Frances wealth comes from Haiti just as
a substantial part of England's wealth
comes from Bengal and other areas of
geography the and left completely
devastated of course in 200 years ago
the Haitians did make a serious mistake
they carried out the first and only
revolution of the 18th century it's the
only one that met the conditions of the
Enlightenment that is it called for
universal freedom none of the others did
that the French and the American
Revolution obviously didn't qualify and
that appalled civilized people they'll
fold them so much that there apparently
was no discussion in the French in
France or in England or the United
States of the very idea that black
slaves could liberate themselves it was
just too appalling when they finally
succeeded at a horrifying cause the
tally round the great French statesman
wrote to James Madison that all
civilized people must be horrified at
the sight of armed Negroes carrying out
massive atrocities against the French
you know just really belong there
and driving Europeans out of their
country and that was in fact the view I
mean Haiti was punished as you said it
was punished by being forced to pay
severe indemnity to France for the crime
of having liberated itself that's not
the only case incidentally the again as
I'm sure you learned that in junior high
school when George Washington in the
middle of the Revolutionary War decided
to wipe out the Iroquois civilization
which was many ways more advanced than
colonists except in modes of warfare and
he succeeded but they had to pay an
indemnity to they D with Clinton the
governor from New York made a treaty
with them after sufficient bashing and
they demanded and do it that they
compensate the colonists for the crimes
they had committed by resisting the
assault that Washington's forces led
against them this was right during the
Revolutionary War incidentally and it's
not the only time in the 1980s Nicaragua
the US was ordered by the World Court to
pay substantial reparations to Nicaragua
for the crime of international terrorism
for which it was condemned but power
relations turned it the other way around
Nicaragua pays indemnities to us the
Vietnamese have to pay the United States
the costs the the costs of running the
client regime in South Vietnam literally
that's what's happening and that's the
way power relations work Haiti's a
particularly grotesque example of it but
it's true
finally the u.s. did recognize Haiti his
last major country to do so and it was
60 years it was 1862 and there was a
reason it was right in the middle of the
civil war they were gonna liberate the
slaves and there was a problem about
what to do with them we had to satisfy
Thomas Jefferson's dictum that the
country had to be as he put it free of
blot or mixture of red or black well the
red part was pretty easy just
exterminate him but the black part they
were hoping that they could be sent
somewhere in fact the United States
recognized Liberia in the same year 1862
the idea is well you necessary get rid
of these savages who don't belong here
and that was the context in which Haiti
and Liberia
were indeed recognized the latter part
of the 19th century the European powers
in the United States were jockeying for
control of the Caribbean which was an
extremely very central area in world
affairs for one reason because it was
the main source of soft drugs tobacco
rum sugar various which were very badly
needed in order to pacify the working
classes in England and others who were
benefiting from early industrialization
by being devastated themselves and for
the a lot of the Wars of the period
we're in fact fought over the Caribbean
for those reasons the actually same
story goes on in India but I want to get
too far off the the British actually
were running the biggest narco
trafficking enterprise in history it
turned out in the late 19th century
interesting story for that reason the
the end result of it was that the u.s.
became the dominant power by the early
part of the last century and Haiti was
still considered a very important colony
plenty of wealth worth having Woodrow
Wilson invaded it in 1915 it's an
example of what's called until today
Wilsonian idealism invaded Haiti the
Dominican Republic and here the memory
split you know the Haitians remember it
one way the United States remembered
another way when Clinton sent the
Marines in 1994 to restore a democracy
I'll get to that there was a lot of
discussion in the press and scholarly
literature and so on and there were a
lot of warnings that Clinton ought to be
careful not to before first following
the course of wilsonian idealism which
tried to impose order in this savage
place in 1915 and in fact the New York
Times even compared the problems he was
facing to those of
holy in the early 18th century the pole
Ian and Wilson both idealists were
trying to impose order on savage places
where the people have homicidal
tendencies and have no experience with
democracy like Napoleon and have no
savage the United States said you read
this right in the the Maine colonists in
the New York Times and Washington Post
and we have to be really careful about
that because the these savage gangs with
their homicidal tendencies on the one
hand the continent makuu to kill that
amount tens of thousands of people under
the dictatorship and another one was the
the military hunter which the US was
actually supporting those was pretending
to be opposed to which it killed I don't
know how many maybe five thousand people
and then the third homicidal gang was
the one was the peasants in the hills
and the people in the slums who had
Kerry who had conducted you know who had
really made this hideous error of having
voted in as president somebody was going
to carry out reformist policies so
between these three gangs with their
homicidal tendencies the seeking revenge
and the traditional Haitian fashion you
know barbarians who have no understand
anything about civilization and stuff
which is exactly it's discussed the US
should be cautious the the MIRR from the
Haitian point of from the US point of
view the the Marine the US the Wilsonian
Wilson occupation was meant was
benevolent so in 1994 leading historians
like David Landis at Harvard explained
that this was a period that really
brought many benefits to Haiti for the
first time but as he pointed out even
the most benevolent occupation does
sometimes arouse resentment so the
Haitians kind of didn't all totally
applaud and others chimed in with the
same story
other distinguished figures the and at
the State Department had explained at
the time and this goes into history that
many of the measures that the you know
Wilson introduced were indeed very
benevolent so for example they induced
the Haitians as the State Department put
it by rather high-handed methods come
back to those but they induced the
Haitians to accept progressive changes
in the Constitution they these backward
people had laws which prevented
foreigners from buying up the entire
country and that is very unprecedented
sticken an economics course you
understand the State Department
reasoning obviously to develop Haiti
needs foreign investment and you can't
expect us investors to put money in
there unless they own it so the best way
to raise Haiti out of its backwardness
is to change the Constitution to allow
Western bought us means us but
corporations to buy up Haiti's lands and
what were the high-handed methods well
the high-handed methods were to send the
Marines in to kick out the Parliament
and then to write a constitution the
author the person took credit for the
Constitution though probably falsely was
Franklin Delano Roosevelt who
incidentally hoped to make it killing on
it himself by buying up some Haitian
lands the new constitution was presented
to the Haitians for a vote because we're
a Democratic Society and it was voted in
by I think ninety-nine point nine
percent of the five percent of the
population go to
so the methods were kind of high-handed
but benevolent and it was also necessary
to impose order there are these savage
gangs with homicidal tendencies so the
Marines had to restore order and they
killed according to the internal Marine
investigation they killed 3,500 of them
according to Haitian historians they
killed 15,000 of them but in any event
they killed enough so that they put down
the resistance the benefit that even the
most benevolent occupation elicits the
they worse they essentially reinstituted
slavery the forced labor there was some
road-building mainly for the
corporations that were coming in to buy
the place up and indeed a lot of it was
brought up by the West very progressive
West means mostly us and they left the
country after 20 years in the hands of a
murderous National Guard trained armed
by the United States run by dictators
exactly the same thing happened in the
next-door Dominican Republic except in
Haiti it was a little more vicious
because it was there was plenty of
racism with regard to the Dominican
Republic but they were only you know
[ __ ] and dagoes and the Thurmond ology
that was used whereas in Haiti they were
[ __ ] and worse they were uppity
[ __ ] so Wilson's Secretary of State
thought it was really comical to see as
he put it [ __ ] talking French really
funny but the and they really had to be
put down so it was it was the sort of
similar in the in the two countries but
two halves of the island but much more
vicious in the in Haiti after that comes
a period of US domination from a little
bit of a distance so the Marines finally
left after 20 years but the u.s. kept
control this is in the 30s now at that
time Haiti according to US producers
agricultural producers Haiti was
producing cotton for example more
efficiently than Nina and
the United States was but that's no good
they had to be taught scientific methods
of Agriculture so during the Second
World War when the United States needed
rubber and other commodities for the war
effort it just took over very large
parts of Haitian agricultural lands and
that turned them over to scientific
methods of production of rubber and
other crops total failure a couple of
tons of rubber came out but the country
was devastated the when peasants were
finally able to go back to what used to
be their lands there was sprightly
desert you know trees hadn't destroyed
the irrigation had been destroyed and
there's nothing there only the first of
a number of scientific experiments there
were others in the nineteen meanwhile
there was under us back dictatorships in
the 1970s the World Bank and US aid
decided to lend their assistance to this
backward country and they initiated a
course of economic development that was
going to turn Haiti into as they put at
the Taiwan of the Caribbean they really
had a bright future ahead of them the
method was to destroy wasteful
activities like agricultural production
for your own use because again if you've
taken an economics course you know it's
much more efficient to buy highly
subsidized US agribusiness exports
instead of wasting your time producing
your own food and or producing anything
else and the idea was to turn Haiti into
an assembly plant essentially for US
corporations and we're very happy to use
Haitian workers they say they're very
docile and disciplined especially when
they've got a military dictatorship and
an army sitting on their necks and they
are much cheaper than the ones and say
Panama
other places where you know haven't had
that much progress so it was going to
and in fact this went along with other
experiments like for example US aid
Falls written about this decided that
the Haiti a lot of the Haitian peasant
economy was based on a very hearty breed
of pigs they were used not only for food
but so big part of the culture but the
scientific agricultural experts decided
that these pigs might be susceptible to
swine flu although there wasn't any so
they decided the best idea would be to
wipe them out which they did and replace
them from with better pigs ones from
Iowa so they brought in fancy pigs from
[Laughter]
there great as long as you keep them in
air-conditioned feed feed them very
fancy food that you buy from us
producers you know the high cost so it
you can actually keep one of these pigs
apparently if you have an income about
103 times that of the annual income of a
peasant in Haiti that was another
contribution meanwhile the economic
miracle preceded Haiti was turned into
on its way to becoming the Taiwan of the
Caribbean during the 1980s wages dropped
by about 50 percent and the agricultural
pretty was self-sufficient in rice
virtually self and in fact a pretty
efficient rice producer it could have
been better but that's inefficient so
they were right they were forced to
adopt the standard neoliberal package
you know structural adjustment package
cut your tariffs privatized that sort of
thing the result was that Haiti now
produces I don't know what it is maybe
50% of its rice maybe less something
like that because Haitian producers no
matter how efficient they are cannot
compete with us
agribusiness which is getting 40 percent
of its income from subsidies government
subsidies under the Reagan
remember this is new this is market free
market theory which has a traditional
form its markets for you but stake
protection for me you know that's the
way it's run for hundreds of years and
that's why the world is divided into a
first world and a third world
actually that's literally very close to
true so Haitian peasants of course can't
compete with highly subsidized US
agribusiness and they were wiped out now
in the neoliberal order this free world
that we live in a Haiti has a remedy
they can impose anti-dumping
restrictions on the United States that
is they can threaten the United States
that they'll close the Haitian market
the US exports the same way that Clinton
does for example when US consumers
prefer Mexican tomatoes or Japanese
super computers he can just close the
market to Mexico and Japan unless they
start threatened to do so unless they
stop the exporting and then they stop
for odd reasons and Haiti can do the
same to the United States because after
all it is a free system it's the World
Trade Organization rules but for some
reason they didn't do it figure out what
but so so Haiti was in fact devastated
by this by this experiment again finally
they did over the US was supporting the
dictators right all the way through
until the last minute when even the army
turned against them at which point the
United States decided that there should
be a transition to democracy then came I
won't go through the details but the
build-up to the election which it was
certain you know they were certain that
the US candidate would win there's no
way you could fail to win and I came out
the wrong way and the u.s. instantly
changed policies it the US aid was was
diverted away from the government
towards anti government agencies every
effort was made to undermine the
government our student came into office
in February 19
the one the refugee policy was changed
in radical violation of international
law and the Universal Declaration of
Human Rights the Carter Administration
had begun blocking barring people who
were fleeing from the paradise that the
US was creating essentially not unusual
take the Mexican border the Mexican word
has been very is artificial like every
border it's the result of conquest and
it's been very porous throughout its
history until 1994 after NAFTA the
border was militarized by under
Clinton's operation gatekeeper and the
reason was because the effects of the
economic miracle in Mexico were going to
drive hundreds of thousands or maybe
more impoverished devastated people of
North and that had to be stopped because
it's our conception of free trade it's
for capital a lot of people and the same
was true in Haiti as the economic
miracle was put into effect people
started fleeing in desperation so the US
Coast Guard Navy blockaded the place
under Carter and just sent him back
that's in total violation of every they
were fleet fleeing real persecution as
well as impoverishment but us and I'm
back under Reagan that was turned into a
formal treaty with the Davidic
leadership but in 1991 u.s. reversed it
a independent democratic government came
in the flow of refugees virtually halted
in fact it turned the other direction as
people were going back in on a moment of
Hope but at that point any refugee who
did come was kind of silent no more
sending him back to Haiti so for seven
months until the military coup the
policy on refugees reversed after the
military coup went back to the old
policy Bush again started returning the
refugees Clinton harshly condemned this
in the nineteen 1992 election and as
soon as he got into office he made it
even harsher and that's
military the government was doing with
was actually in the seven months it had
it was getting considerable praise from
international institutions even from
secret State Department reports that
were leaked it was for progressive
measures for eliminating needless
bureaucracy for getting rid of
oppression so when they were getting
substantial loans in fact which made it
even worse because the country might
fall out of US control military coup
came along the Organization of American
States declared an embargo the Bush
administration almost immediately
undermined the embargo by exempting the
US producers which happened to include
plants owned by the patient Ailee rich
meb's family and others they were
excluded from the embargo and imports
were allowed in the explanation for this
was again our benevolence the New York
Times explained that this was done this
was what they called fine-tuning the
embargo to help the people of Haiti by
exempting US exports the people who they
were helping were bitterly protesting
and the military Hunta and its wealthy
supporters were overjoyed but it was all
done for the people of Haiti just as
we've always done it got worse under
Clinton considerably worse furthermore
both the bush in the Clinton
administration authorized the Texaco oil
company to violate presidential
directives and provide oil to the hunt
anybody who was there could see the oil
coming in but the US government and CIA
testified to Congress that no oil was
coming in you know there's oil forms
that you saw it didn't exist and the
picture you know they turned out right
the day before the invasion to restore
democracy it was revealed that both Bush
and Clinton had authorized that oil as
the centerpiece of an embargo also the
US was arming and training Haitian
officers the head of the paramilitary
organization frappe which is responsible
for
the deaths was on the CIA payroll
conceded but now officially the US was
opposing the hunt in fact that was
supporting it then it restored democracy
after the they thought the popular
organizations had taken a sufficient
beating and thousands had been killed
and they've been sufficiently terrorized
and the terror was extreme I mean I
don't want to talk about it because you
know much more than I do but I was there
for a few days at the peak of the terror
and you know I've been in places that
are under severe repression I just came
back from Turkey a couple days ago we're
in the southeast where I was there's 15
million people living in a dungeon you
know in an area where millions of people
have been driven out of of the
surrounding region which has just been
devastated in some of the worst ethnic
cleansing and atrocities of the 1990s
for which you and I paid and
incidentally this was done with the u.s.
support and military aid and that's why
you don't hear about yeah but it
compared with you know the people there
are under severe oppression police
everywhere army everywhere but there
other place I've never seen anything
like what I saw in the slums of Haiti
back in 1993 when people were literally
afraid to talk the only thing they would
say is things like there are eyes
everywhere you know but after this
terror was had succeeded they thought in
achieving its ends our steed was
permitted to return but on a condition
namely the condition that he accept the
program of the defeated us candidate so
if you which is precisely what the
wording that was used he said you've got
to direct the renovated government has
to direct its action that has to focus
it's its policies on the needs of civil
society primarily that means the private
sector Nash both national and
national so us investors our Haitian
civil society but the people in the
slums and the hills aren't and the very
harsh structural adjustment was program
was imposed I won't go through the
details because it's too late but it
succeeded in further devastating what
was left of the economy and the Haitians
still resisted that's why they haven't
understood what democracy is and they'll
have to come to learn this you know two
hundred years we've been trying to teach
it to them and they still haven't gotten
the idea so you can understand why this
is important
Thank You professor Chomsky for laying
the groundwork for dr. farmers current
analysis of the Haitian situation
economic political in the backyard of
democracy thank you thank you it's a
real privilege to be here with all of
you and the two of you I want to thank
Dinesh and and the many people who
organized this forum and you just use
the term the uses of Haiti for tonight
and I was very grateful but I would add
that when no one wrote the introduction
the uses of Haiti and he wrote this book
is slated for Oblivion I want to thank
you for that no that was very helpful as
a marketing ploy
and of course as as ever he is he's
correct I just came from the hospital
and I was rounding and and I was seeing
a patient I was late I said I gotta go
I'm giving a talk with with noam chomsky
one of the people on my team by the way
said why can't he come around with this
you know and but the other person said
why why are you guys talking together I
mean you know if you guys agree on
everything and I said well he's about
the only American intellectual I know
who's actually telling the truth about
what's going on in Haiti and I wish I
could make a long list and and maybe
there maybe I'm missing some things I
suspect that I am but you know I think
that in in the 20 years that I've been
working there can can we make that
obedient to my every whim here that
thing in the 20 years that I've been
working there I think that a lack of
forthright analysis has never been so
wanting and I I'm a physician and mostly
do medical work but I feel compelled to
to to make up something as he fixes the
slide machine anyway could you tell this
is gonna sound great on radio as slide
presentations always do
that's probably you probably you know
made this not work on off maybe yeah
it's not real remote there we go
is it on Nancy don't don't take don't
take away from my time that was their
fault I'm that no matter how you look at
Haiti and I look at it as a physician
does the situation is is grave and I'll
spend a fair amount of time talking
about what's going on now and I will not
spend a fair amount of time going over
the statistics I'll be glad to share
them with any of you from the sources
that we think are fairly reliable but
life expectancy has dropped in Haiti
over the past few years people don't
have access to clean water births are
not attended it's very dangerous to have
a child in Haiti in one study for every
thousand children who were born alive
1,400 women died in childbirth the
highest by far in the hemisphere one of
the highest in the world and so as
someone who works with many others who
are providing health care services to
people living in rural Haiti into one of
the poorer parts of Haiti which is
saying a lot we need to be concerned and
engaged in understanding what is driving
forward this this really wall of
pathology and I'm of course thinking
about pathology in terms of individual
patients illness but the pathology as
noam has said is social in origin and
isn't rent as transnational in origin
and is historically rooted in a series
of processes that unfortunately for many
of our commentators did happen more than
five minutes ago and so understanding
what's happening now means that we have
to understand what has happened in the
past the decline of the Haitian economy
in recent years has been severe it's
then a you know one of the most striking
trends in Latin America this is from the
United Nations Development Programme a
what I've called here economic
evolution shows that negative growth
rates of the economy and and there are
many ways of looking at misery I do have
to wonder who puts together things like
the human suffering index it's not
really what I would like to do is a
pastime but when something called the
human suffering index was put together
and first published not too long ago
Haiti was the only country in the
hemisphere that figured in the top five
it was number three and the only two
other countries ahead of it were both in
the middle of a civil war and in
reflecting on this data of Haiti ranking
number three in terms of human suffering
you know you came to think about the
conditions there as a sort of war and
it's a war of the rich against the poor
basically and the rich of course are
sitting in many different places not so
much in Haiti right now but they're
there too and waging a sort of war and a
patient who I saw in the clinic said
it's it's like a war here every day the
fight for food and wood and water and
that's what the situation is reduced to
in Haiti every day the fight for food
and wood and water would of course to
cook the food so Haiti has become and
this is from the Economist the nightmare
next door and it's very important to
find out why and I'm gonna die
you should look back at the characters
of the American occupation during that
time the character is not of the
American occupation but really in the
American press at the time of the
occupation of Haiti which were very
similar to the one I just showed you now
back to this question of more than five
minutes ago this was a comment made by
john lecarre the English novelist who
wrote in the nation about a war we
cannot win and no I'm already said it
suggesting that there is a historical
context for the recent atrocities is by
implication to make excuses for them
anyone who is with us doesn't do that
doesn't do historical analysis anyone
who does is against us and he's
referring very specifically to he was
referring this essay to discussions
about what has
what happened here in the September 11th
now I'm going to of course know I'm used
another expression the those with their
boot on the neck don't want people who
have their neck constrained in that
manner to be asking questions about
history or making comments and I'm going
to do just that in talking about echoing
many of the things that were he said but
I want to add a couple to that and I can
speed through this part because no one
went through it already the first
European settlement in the new world was
in Haiti and that's where fact one of
those three ships can't remember which
one I'm sorry Nome will of course know
found off foundered off the coast of
Haiti in 1492 and part of the wreckage
was used to make one of the the first
European settlement in in the new world
and the fact that as many as eight
million people could have lived on that
island then in 1492 is just an
astounding and horrific thought and did
that figure of eight million comes from
demographers at the University of
California who were using mathematical
models to try and figure out how densely
populated the country was in 1492 an
astounding and terrible series of events
but has already been mentioned if the
Indians wouldn't do it slaves as slaves
then we needed more Hardy slaves and
this is a actually the subject of great
interest in Haitian scholarship in
history was the the change from using
indigenous slaves to kidnapping people
in western Africa just as it a couple of
asides to give an idea about the scale
of what it took to make Haiti the most
profitable colony in the world in
European history probably it took up to
29,000 slaves a year as imports so Haiti
was in fact the number one destination
in the new world for slaves it was ahead
of of Cuba and far ahead of the other
islands around their head of the
American South and in fact that fact
21,000 was at the peak and that fact
demographic fact is one of the reasons
that led to the Haitian Revolution is
that there were just so many slaves
compared to slave master
that the the numbers were eventually on
the side of the enslaved who staged a
series of revolts throughout the new
world but only one of them was really
successful the Haitian rebellion in
terms of leading to you know victory to
the slaves and from 1697 on it was the
French who were the slave masters and
they replaced over the ensuing century
the the Spanish and made Haiti into a
really earnest producer of tropical
produce coffee by the way please don't
be knocking soft drugs coffee sugar
cotton indigo other things that couldn't
be brought grown in Europe and Haiti was
as has been mentioned providing about
two-thirds of all European tropical
produce by the time of the French
Revolution the French excuse me the
French Revolution I've got to get that
right and I think the Haitians
or what would be the in agreement that
the patients here tonight I know the
Haitians in Haiti are in agreement that
the none of these revolutions in Europe
were really serious as the Haitians
would say that they weren't serious
because any serious revolution would of
course liberate these slaves when the
the slave owning mulatos went to haitian
native france to speak in front of the
national parliament in france the the
so-called revolutionary parliament they
went to argue for the right of mulatos
to own slaves so again i have to ask how
how resonant is that that performance of
the first haitian lead with their
performance in the ensuing 200 years I
work with I'll just say it right right
now I work in rural Haiti with people
who call themselves peasants and who
have very much
slanted if you will towards truth in my
view the way that I see this but that
was one of the first gambits of the
emerging haitian elite who owned slave
was to have the French recognized their
right to own slaves
so the real Haitians the slaves who
revolted were also leading a revolt
against the mulatto elite who wanted to
canoe to continue owning slaves and of
course not all the mulatto
in this term by the way is from colonial
times there was a and and of course it's
a social construct I'm just using the
terms that are used in inside Haiti but
there was about 28,000 French living in
Haiti about maybe 40,000 so-called
mulatos mixed of French and and hate in
African descent and about half a million
adult slaves and so there were also
children and the adults lives were men
and women and working and counted as
slaves and in fact the the the French
kept rather meticulous records of the
colony and so we have a lot of quantity
you know information about what life was
like during the slavery now and during
the colony and I'll just go through some
of that I mentioned already that the the
the size and scope of this little
factory which is the size of the state
of Maryland was just churning out wealth
no one mentioned that many French cities
owed their wealth the cities of Bordeaux
for example which if you've seen as a
beautiful city was virtually built out
of this money and all of the big coastal
cities of France came from this trade
they were built up during the slave
trade and in fact the same buildings
that are there now that everyone admires
is so beautiful were really the fruits
of this triangular trade the impact of
course in Haiti on the lives of these
slaves was was terrible one in three
slaves dying within the first three
years of life in the in Haiti in the
colony Haiti by the way was the name of
the colony before the French can't the
Europeans came it's a local word it
means high country mountainous country
was the indigenous term and it was taken
back by the leaders of the Haitian
Revolution after the Europeans were
defeated now this is from from a Haitian
who was a slave during before the
Revolution and was one of the few people
writing you know of course in the United
States we really don't have a lot of
testimonies from slaves narratives from
slaves and it's a very interesting area
of historical scholarship but in Haiti
there actually are because
to the revolution many people wrote
about their experience and I won't read
this to you here you can read it but I
know that it says have they not and then
list the crimes against the the slaves
that the French perpetrated now the
Revolution began in 1791 the stone said
the only real revolution 18th century
and went on for a decade more and one of
the amazing things about the Revolution
was that Haiti was considered so
important to the French economy again
like but like Bangladesh now considered
the International basket case of the
hemisphere that the largest European
Armada ever to set forth from Europe
since or before left France under
Napoleon's direction to retake Haiti
eighty thousand French troops and also
conscripts from Poland and other places
that the democratically minded Napoleon
was taking over in Europe eighty
thousand troops
forty thousand Navy and forty thousand
ground troops went to Haiti which again
even to this day is just astounding to
think of that sort of movement of troops
across the Atlantic and he sent his
brother-in-law general LeClair who was
married to Pauline Bonaparte who died in
Haiti in northern Haiti never returned
Pauline Bonaparte also lived there and
this was again at a horrible cost to the
to the Haitian people they started
calling themselves Haitians as went
during the revolution during the war
and when I say horrible cost the general
LeClair wrote a letter back to his
brother-in-law at one point saying we
can never retake this colony unless we
kill every single man or woman who has
carried epaulettes meaning of slaves who
were now in the in the army which is
being led by the the leaders of the
slave revolt and every child above the
age of 13 who has done so as well this
is in the correspondence between general
LeClair and Napoleon shortly before he
died
so they he saw he already was sending
messages back home that this was going
to not going to work that they were
going to fail unless they had a campaign
to wipe out
wipe out the you know all of the adults
and by adults he as he said thirteen
years and over now what happened after
the Revolution has already been
commented on here
the revolution ended into the battle I
just showed you the Battle of LTO and in
November of 1803 and on January 1st
the Haitians declared independence the
first independent nation in Latin
America they took the French tricolour
color and ripped out the front the white
part and of course saying we're getting
rid of the whites and the Haitian flag
was initially the red and blue bicolor
that was recently restored and in that
year they declared Haiti a safe haven
for any indigenous person and any
escaped slave in in the new world so
that was another part of these
unprogressive features of their
constitution know I'm mentioned also
that the it said no European no
foreigner were ever set foot in this
country as a land owner and that was
part of the the Dessalines constitution
of 1804 and decently and as you Mart
might imagine is regarded as the father
of Haitian independence by the Haitians
and regarded as a butcher by the
Americans and their friends in Europe
now how does this work itself out Nancy
used the word trade embargo but actually
what we usually do in Haiti is not a
trade embargo and and you clarified that
by saying unfavorable conditions for the
Haitians and very favorable conditions
for the the Europeans and Americans but
it's not a trade embargo it was a worse
it was a refusal to recognize Haiti's
independence as a state and as has
already been said this went on for till
in 1862 and this is just stuff from
again the US official congressional
record you know I know him gave me
advice years ago he said if you're gonna
write books like that one try to use
formal US official sources and I've
followed that over over the years it's a
it's a great source
I mean of information about our policy
and this is 1824 a senator from South
Carolina since this is being taped I'll
read it our policy with regard to Haiti
Haiti is plain
we can never acknowledge her
independence the peace and safety of a
large portion of our union forbids us
even to discuss it and this was the
standard fair inside the the great halls
of democratic United States during those
years those decades in which we were
exploiting relations to Haiti but not
recognizing here's the the kicker to me
and this was mentioned to the Haitians
of course still were growing tropical
produce after the abolition of slavery
however they were doing it with free
people
peasants mostly and coffee is something
you don't need to grow in plantations
you can grow on small plots of land on
hillsides and it became it replaced
sugar and cotton as the main exports of
Haiti because peasants could grow
without working on plantations and I can
promise you that the Haitian peasantry
has never wanted to work on plantations
and with I can't imagine why not that
conditions had been so pleasant before
so it's been a long struggle the land
reform struggle in Haiti is very
interesting and very poignant but the
the bottom line is most of the Haitian
people refuse to work under anything
that looked like plantation conditions
and so we're exporting coffee more than
any other crop but the the amazing and
you know horrible thing is that when
people talk about reparations now and
Nancy mentioned the Durban declaration
that the Haitians already paid
reparations to the slave owners the
slave owners and the the size of the
payment is was astounding 150 million
francs and according to a fairly sober
late 18th 19th century Haitian historian
who looked at this early 20th century
who looked at this you know in
retrospect just aghast he said that from
a relatively balanced economy prior to
the payment of this massive debt to the
French - this led to a major disruption
that really continued to have its impact
in the Haitian economy throughout the
rest of the 19th century this this
payment of
and the French at this time we're also
dominating Haitian trade and that went
on
along with struggles from the British
and the Germans and some of you might
not know that at one point in late teen
19th 19th century the Germans and I
believe it was under Kaiser because
Kaiser sent of some very lovely envoys
to Haiti one of whom took the Haitian
flag and smeared excrement on it in the
bay of port-au-prince the the Envoy the
military envoy of the Kaiser of Germany
that was the the way that the civilized
societies of Europe chose to mark their
respect for Haiti and this went on for
some decades Europe France Britain I
mean France Germany and Britain vying
with the United States for influence but
by the late the end of the century there
was really no competition although when
the Americans sent in the Marines in
1915 they claimed one reason was to
limit German influence in Haiti which
had already been virtually erased in the
previous two years previous to decades
so when the Marines went in then began
began the intensified series of events
and processes of development and
scientific development that have made
Haiti the paradise that it is today I
would just add that the modern Haitian
Army was created by an act of Congress
US Congress and signed into existence in
Washington and I'm gonna soon switch to
a sort of local analysis but when I talk
about the valley in which we've been
working for a long time you'll see very
similar kinds of events that are really
transnational I mean the modern nation
Army how often do we acknowledge that
the you know the army that you know we
suddenly declared a rogue army after you
know really uncompromising and ongoing
support for many decades was really
created by the American occupiers not
just trained but created and then in
came the agribusiness and missionaries
of the early part of the last century
20th century and the the kind of
appropriations of land
no one mentioned in his talk were really
huge plots of land to us owned these
were usually with these sort of
partnerships with the Haitian elites so
that there would be Haitian elite
ownership meaning wealthy people in
Haiti and US ownership of a you know a
plantation no mentioned rubber but
during the world the world war two Haiti
also began growing season hemp or size
low hemp in order to make big ropes for
the the ships Haiti was the the leading
this is before nylon replaced those he
was also the world suddenly the world's
leading producer of of hemp because they
could switch this flip the switches on
these plantations rubber hemp whatever
was necessary locally I'm kidding
because of course I don't know that hemp
has many utilities locally I guess you
can make baskets or things out of it now
what was our what can we read in that
great journal that our National Journal
of record the New York Times already
been quoted today instability was the
pretext reducing European German
influence during the war the
convalescent ICN oh ma can spelled wrong
sorry was basically led the united
states pleat administrative control of
haiti including the ability as was
mentioned to rewrite the Constitution to
remove those very unprofessional and the
troops stayed in Haiti until 1934 and
you already heard about the resistance
the Haitian people gave spirited
resistance to the occupation and that
resistance was based among the peasantry
in the very place where I work central
Haiti central plateau that's where the
resistance was based it did not come
from the Haitian elite although there
were some intellectuals who opposed the
the American operation in their own
somewhat timorous way compared to the
peasantry who really opposed it the
occupation of Haiti led to the
restoration of forced labor crews knock
off a the major roads built during that
time were built largely with
labor there's grotesque documentation of
this available in the historical record
and it was very interesting to see how
it gets retold and sanitized and retold
in the non Haitian accountings of this
but the Haitian accountings had the
added advantage of being correct now
this led rather seamlessly in fact to
the Duvalier family dictatorship that is
there was no no one could come to power
in Haiti without the benediction of the
US government from the time of the
occupation of course when it was overt
and formal but in from 1934 until until
1990 until 1990 that was really the the
prerequisite for coming to power was to
have us backing and you know from the US
ambassador and from other from the
latest whatever US ID might be called on
that particular day it says or the other
US institutions and so most of all
Duvalier you know again I think there's
a lot of confusion about this Francois
Duvalier was was supported by the the
American Embassy in Haiti the in 1957 he
received the report of the embassy
because you read a lot about the United
States spirited resistance to the
devaluate Raider ship you know of course
not in Haiti but in the United States
but it was pretty unremitting our
support for the devaluate dictatorship
there were a couple of years where the
activities of the dictatorship were so
terrible I mean just to give an example
which again seems to have escaped
everybody's mind when they're talking
about the reign of terror that exists
now the Duke I mean Francois Duvalier
would kills have someone killed and then
display the body across from the airport
for you know days so that's not very
subtle symbolism according to
anthropologist with whom I work and this
was this was again obviously meant to
draw attention to the fact that the
dictatorship would counter would
tolerate no and any sort of challenge to
its power every single independent
radio newspaper yeah the the few
independent minded intellectuals that
may have theoretically existed at that
time they left and or were killed and it
took about you know ten years to really
shut down any sort of threat from the
military from the Army which was the
primary who which had been previously
the primary determine of who would who
would come to power the United States
and the Haitian military not that those
two institutions had any relation of
course and so Francois Duvalier
undermined the army and the opposition
silence the opposition very completely
and spent the rest of his very long
reign he used to say policy Mattia I'm
going from the palace to the cemetery
cemetery you know and he did he was
there until he died
and then his 19 year old son who had
from what I understand had never left
Haiti became president of the oldest
Republic in Latin America a 19 year old
son who had you know of course an
advanced degree from the Fletcher School
anyway I'm kidding that was a joke i won
well anyway I better be good I'm on tape
sorry so
now 1971 that happened and and the years
from 71 to 86 world years of decline for
reasons that are acknowledged and there
were really thousands of refugees you
heard about the Welcome they got from us
a really amazingly repugnant policy
actually the seizing and interception of
refugee ships on the high seas and then
the return of refugees is again in
violation of many treaties to which the
United States is a formal Signet
signatory several signatory and but it
didn't bother us too much and then there
was political unrest that began in 85
and was very much associated with a
popular movement that is a movement
based as has been mentioned among the
the rural poor and the urban poor in
slums and it was an amazing thing to be
living in Haiti at that time and be
working there because I hadn't had never
seen anything like that in my experience
as an American there was so much popular
support for the popular movement that
virtually every member every person who
lived in the village where I was living
and working and man living and working
everyone was part of the popular
movement was it without any exception
and in 1990 when at the last minute ari
steed announced his candidature you know
you could practically hear the stampede
of people going to register to vote
because after what happened in nineteen
eighty eight eighty seven which is
unstinting support from the United
States government for the Haitian
military and here's a just a number for
you over 200 million dollars in aid
passed through the hands of the military
hunter I actually I'm going to risk
saying this on tape I spoke with someone
today a prominent in a prominent US
office and with the fate of Haiti in its
hands I would just say that and he was
saying well you know I would really like
to see the you know and the frozen aid
released we what we need to do is get
the government to you know promise to
how to do that
to use the aid in an open and clear
manner and be subject to the various
forms of scrutiny et cetera and I
couldn't resist I couldn't stop myself I
knew I just sort of said nothing but I
said I was standing in the IC unit and a
surgical ICU you know with a phone and
trying to write a note about a patient
listening this guy knowing that you know
I didn't have to listen the whole time
but I said to him well you know I've
been working in Haiti 20 years and you
know during the dictatorship the there
was never any sort of real scrutiny of
US aid and during the military hunches
why now and and then he just said big
you're right I really don't understand
US foreign policy and I said I did not
say I'm going to give a talk with Noam
Chomsky I just said I I got to get back
to seeing patients and call you tomorrow
now you already heard that we trained a
lot of those very delightful military
officers who held sway during these
times I'm gonna skip ahead to what
happened in 1987 and skipped through
some of the stuff where we work but in
1987 there was a massacre of voters at
the polling place now again that's more
than five minutes ago so everyone's
forgotten but can you imagine I was
there in Haiti that day and can you
imagine seeing groups of people lined up
to vote and then you know seeing them
taken out at the polls and this was
really incredible and and of course in
the middle of a military junta the reign
of a military junta I mean granted it is
rather far-fetched to suggest that the
military may have had something to do
with this but it was pretty clear to the
Haitians that this was basically the
action of the Haitian army and who which
has had no non Haitian enemies and you
know in in a hundred hundreds of years
only Haitians have been the enemies of
the Haitian army and so a lot of
Haitians were not gonna vote in 1990
until our seed registered and then it
was something like a million people
registered the last in the last two days
and so to you know expiry
that to see that happen and to
experience that was really very
eye-opening for me in the village where
were you know where we work there was
this there's this one woman who's a good
friend of mine who's a what we used to
call when I was growing up a lunch lady
she makes lunch in the school cafeteria
and she was a she was and remains as do
most of them a very devout arrested
supporter and I told her that I had been
listening to the radio and I heard a
pole from port-au-prince and she said
what's a pole and I said well that's
when people go out in the street and ask
people how they're gonna vote I said
what did it show and I said that iris-t
would win over 50 percent of the vote in
the first elections without a runoff and
she said well that can't be true and I
said I thought you you were a big artist
he'd support her and and and she said oh
yeah he'll win ninety-nine percent of
the vote if it's a reelection and so she
thought that was unlikely that even
there were eleven candidates that he
would win with only a plurality in the
first round with fifty something and in
fact he did win with a much higher floor
ality in the in the first election there
were never any run offs because you know
it's I mean now granted we always have
very clear outcomes in our elections as
well and that a run offs are not
necessary but you know it's still
learning experience for me even though
you know I'm American so therefore
democratic by training now
I'm gonna because in the interest of
skipping ahead I'm going to just close
by talking about health conditions in
Haiti because it's important and I think
every everybody here should know about
this the the health situation in Haiti
is dire by any kind of criteria and this
is a this is a an image of an image
picture of a girl with typhoid typhoid
fever which I get along with
tuberculosis you know and other what the
Haitians call stupid diseases actually
are the primary determinants of life and
death and in Haiti so of course one of
the first things to do is to have a
public health system that takes on these
problems this is by the way I can't
resist putting this image right this is
this is a child with anthrax and um you
know must be because Haiti is a
terrorist state that they mean
that they have anthrax there that was
actually brought up in the American
press and you know Haiti has real
anthrax meaning the kind that's caused a
zoonosis contact with with animals in
this the case of this girl she has
antioxidant and her someone died of the
anthrax in her in this outbreak she came
in with another an adult and they got
treated and did fine as one does but
someone died in their village anyway
someone mentioned in the American press
that Haiti could be a terrorist State
manufacturing anthrax and in a Haitian
veterinarian said it's just ridiculous
and what you can't respond to every one
of these nutso suggestions and I had
this image in my mind of you know a
group of Haitian goats getting together
and say let's get a lab going and get
some of this stuff off of our fur and
anyway now I told you about Election Day
1987 and I mean this is inside a school
you know and I it's just it's just awful
what happened and so the the the the
willingness to participate in this
election of 1990 was really a strong
statement about commitment to democracy
and so I mentioned what happened already
but after seven months there was a
violent military coup and you know this
and it's already been discussed by
know'm which led to the deaths of really
thousands of people and massive internal
migration addition to external migration
internal migration because we were
working in rural Haiti and people fled
from the slums out to where we work and
so we saw you know enormous changes and
it was just a huge an ongoing disruption
for a long time and as Noam said it was
very frightening and not theoretically I
mean I personally know a number of
people who were killed during that time
including a including a Haitian
businessman one of the only ones to to
say well you know the popular movement
is probably a good thing since the clue
it includes about 90% of the Haitian
population and his brother was murdered
down to in downtown port-au-prince and
during a memorial Mass for his brother
he was shot in the
and killed during mass by paramilitary
forces and and this this is the level
and this is a prominent businessman who
you know was very wealthy actually who
you know made the mistake of not doing
what business people in Haiti are
supposed to do and saying you know these
savages from the hills and slums really
cannot play a role in in the future of
Haiti and then again this is the embargo
has already been discussed that the the
fake embargo now we have a real embargo
mind you but the fake one I mean I again
I'm sitting in Haiti reading the New
York Times and thinking what on earth
are they talking about you know this
does not mum my mother is a librarian
and so she was like she was you know
sending me things this was when we had
an office in port-au-prince before we
had to close it down during those years
because of death threats and
intimidation we finally just closed up
our operation in port-au-prince
completely but she was sending me these
things and I'd said this is just not at
all what's happening but the image that
comes to mind is you know we were able
to detect refugees and boats from you
know miles away with radar and but a oil
tanker going from steaming from Texas to
port-au-prince didn't show up on the
radar
so I mean granted there are small boats
and all those tankers but so fine-tuning
I remember that was Barbara Chrisette
wasn't in wrote that fine-tuning the
embargo that was the New York Times
problem she probably want a million
awards fuel it sir and things like that
and no no one has already covered the
embargo so I'm gonna go ahead and turn
to the real embargo now here's where we
end up after as Nancy said use the term
impoverished meant because it implies a
historical process takes a long time
to impoverish the place but here's where
we end up you know with again the the
the most impoverished country in the
hemisphere which of course only
coincidentally is the country most
linked to the United States for the
longest time I mean that's surely just a
erroneous Association and the the part
that that I see on and concerns me just
in terms of everyday practice as a
physician is that the impact of this on
health of is of course profound and so
most of the patients we see have the
diseases that poverty engenders
and sustains and therefore they could be
and they can be prevented and treated at
the end you know distally as we say in
medicine but and that's what I do I'm
sorry I mean it's you know kind of what
I was trying to do is sort of get people
when it's too late
but the real responses to this will be
of course determine outside of in my
view outside of rural Haiti this is
where this is the receiving end this is
not the determining end but the the
slogans are I mean that the numbers are
terrible well here let me just give you
this one example to close my comments so
what would a public health
infrastructure do in Haiti
what would a government do if instead of
being interested in you know imprisoning
and arresting what if it really wanted
to promote help well it would have to
have capital you'd have to have funds
you can't do public health with no money
you can't you know if you knew the money
that gets spent in Massachusetts in on
public health of you I think I was
astounded when I saw the numbers it's
something like more of all China and
India in just our little tiny state of
six million people it's it's in it's
good hey we like this you want to you
know have huge investment in things why
not choose public health rather than you
know bombers and things like that I'm
all for it sign me up
however you can't do it with no money
you have to have money so not
coincidentally Haiti of course was
completely broke just like it was at the
end of the Revolution they everything
had been burned down and destroyed in
fact it may be worse now than then
because some parts of Haiti were not
burned down and and the store the soil
was still fertile and deforestation had
not done what it is done now but a
government shouldn't want to do this we
have the Ministry of Health put together
with consultation which they did a this
is called Oh like this word health
reform okay but reorganization was a an
inoffensive one and so they put together
I had nothing to do with this I'm just I
just I went and found this it's a matter
of public record
I was very easy to get from the Haitian
authorities by the way and a little bit
more difficult to get out of the
inter-american Development Bank
authorities but on July 21st nineteen
eighty ninety eight the Haitian
government and the American Development
Bank which is a very in
important institution in Latin America
in terms of you know things with the a
couple of notable exceptions all of
these of you know officialdom countries
go through these mechanisms and they
sign the loan they for twenty two point
five million dollars which is a huge
amount for the Haitian Ministry of
Health by the way in that anthrax
outbreak I think it was the anthrax
break it may have been an outbreak of
men and Jericho meningitis I sent an
email from central Haiti to a friend of
mine who was a with the Ministry of help
saying you know we're it was minute
meningococcal meningitis I said we're
having an outbreak of meningococcemia
Menninger cockle disease and a baby had
just died and we we saw another case
with purpura fulminant and saw another
case the next day so we alerted them and
I got no answer back because they were
supposed to come out and investigate and
that's what they had asked us to do and
a couple months later I saw the guy who
was like I said a friend of mine who's a
very earnest good person and I said what
why didn't you come out to investigate
this and he said we didn't have any gas
for the Jeep so and I said you know that
was the end of that discussion because I
thought you know I'm not gonna be
rebuking people for not having gas it's
like that's sort of our foreign policy
yell at people for being poor so now
let's yell at that the the Haitian
government and for being poor we do that
very well by the way with with very
little in the way of critical response
from you know the the mandarins of
American foreign policy and including
the intellectuals again I don't know you
you follow this more closely than I do I
haven't seen a lot of commentary on what
it is exactly we're doing but it looks a
lot to me like yelling at the poor as
really powerful wealthy people now a
nation rather so this was the goal of
the the loan and you know it's pretty
standard fare really quite dull to read
actually i can't believe i i i had to
have help from my co-workers getting to
it's very it was boring and the the
goals these are the project goals i'm
just summarizing for them for you but
basically they were very standard public
health goals reduce infant mortality
reduce and you know there was a plan and
it was approved by the the haitian
government and and it got stalled in
parliament because the
a famously obstructionist Parliament
that's by the way that's why the
Haitians voted in March this is the
famous disputed elections in March of
2000 nothing to do with the presidential
elections that would happen later on
that year the Haitians went out and
tried to do clean slate for one party so
they could get rid of the obstructionist
Parliament and they did you know they
everybody went out and voted for the
same the same party in order to have the
obstructionist Parliament not block
every sort of sort of Haitian gridlock
of blocking every every and I would say
this is by any kind of standard a
reasonable proposal and you know what
you'd want a public health project to
look like so in any case then what
happened well in October 1998 the
Haitian Ministry of Health's presented
the project to the legislature and I
just wrote obstructionists because
that's what they were doing they were
basically trying to block everything
that came from the the the central
government this was not under I received
by there this is under a pile and in
then after the March elections had led
to a non obstructionist Parliament that
is in a parliament that would would vote
to approve proposals from the central
government it was ratified there and the
money the inter-american Development
Bank said okay money's on the way this
is announced in the papers as official
and then there were new conditions put
on and this is when I started hearing
about this you know if you're sitting
there and we're all Haiti and your
number of patients is increased by two
fold in 18 months and you have seen
various clinics and hospitals closed
down in the region and you know your
doctors and nurses are saying we can't
see all these patients and getting
rather they're just it's just not
possible to see if there's a medical
staff of eight or nine people to see
four or five hundred patients in a day
and so that you get you have I'm the
medical director so they're coming to me
with complaints is that we can't see all
these patients and I say what can I do
these are all Haitian colleagues and say
you know your country the country is
sick we have to see the patients but I'm
just waiting for this IDB thing to go
through so that the other institutions
can be reopened as
the stated intention of the Haitian
Ministry of Health so I'm waiting so I
started asking where's that loan that
would allow the other public health
because this is you know this is a
private charity hospital that is as a
private hospital doing the work of the
public health infrastructure so we're
just waiting we started looking into it
and we found out we started following it
and the most amazing thing I heard was
last summer when I found out the America
Haitian government was actually paying
credit Commission's and interest on a
loan that had not been disbursed and I
said you know I'm not an economist or a
banker you know I you know I'm sorry I'm
just a physician anthropologist but
isn't that illegal you know is that can
you do that and this is last year this
is still going on today yeah I don't
care if my 30 minutes are up I'm just
getting warmed up all right and they
were having their arms twisted and I'm
telling you the from what I understand
the the and I know this to be true the
Ministry of Health has no money the this
size let me just give you one another
little ironic thing the size of the
Brigham and Women's Hospital budget okay
where I work and some of you have been
there is larger than the Republic of
Haiti and you read in the newspaper
maybe a couple days you know that
Brigham Women's Hospital has a hundred
and sixty three million dollars a year
in support just from the INH the inh is
isoniazid sorry nih inh is a drug to
treat tuberculosis forgive my
did I really do that anyway nice scuse
him anyway so this is what we're left
with and this is what I'm gonna close
with there they are you know you know
people can say okay well what are you
doing getting involved in this stuff or
as I heard today during rounds why are
you giving a talk with Noam Chomsky
that's true isn't it and he didn't say
it but well here's why because we're
sick of seeing sick patients who don't
want to be sick who've already you know
worked so hard and again I take the view
that Nancy does not just you know even
they worked hard for about two hundred
and ten years by my count to have a
society in which everyone including poor
people and in back 200 years ago
including slaves had a say in what
happens to their destiny that seems to
me the clear message of all the Haitian
popular movements from the 18th century
to now is that the Haitian people are
saying we don't want to be left out of
the you know true democracy we want to
have a say in this and to see the same
people who I regard is extremely valiant
be reduced to sitting outside of our
clinic and going there tonight before
and sleeping on the ground to see the
physicians is it's you know it just is
it's more than disheartening for those
of us who are working there and of
course we know very well that the the
source of these illnesses are social
conditions and we know because we've
heard now twice I hope what causes the
the social conditions that we see now in
Haiti and when I speak to friends and
family and co-workers and I tell them
this story about you know the the only
two countries by the way this is after
Durban the meeting not the Durban AIDS
meeting which I did go to but the Durban
meeting that Nancy went to on racism the
declaration of Durban which many of you
may have read has very pointed language
on reparations owned owed to
post-colonial societies and the two
major destinations for slaves kidnapped
from West Africa in the new world where
Cuba and Haiti and there are those the
only two countries under formal aid
embargoes by
the United States so that's right now
how we're paying reparations to Haiti
thank you very much
[Applause]
you heard it reparations I think from
both professor Chomsky and dr. farmer we
have a sense of the sustainability of
and the resilience of Haitian people in
their determination to have a democracy
to be part of the governance of their
Island and to be part of the process of
self-determination over and over we've
challenged have been challenged
interference coming from a number of
places but we've steadfastly kept on our
desire for democracy and for autonomy
I think after hearing these two
prominent scholars I'd like to give a
chance to you guys the emerging scholars
to air your thoughts and ask questions
and perhaps offer some guidance to the
scholarly and powerful people who have
interfered with the sovereignty of the
Haitian people go ahead
do you want to take the microphone did
everybody hear the question the first
question was what about the United
Nations I never mentioned what is the
United Nations again oh oh the thing in
New York
I'll let no him take this but I just
want to say one thing before I pass on
to him is having lived in Haiti for 20
years I have developed a deep suspicion
of the International trilateral groups
like that I mean the Organization of
American States has been quite Craven
and is not willing this certainly will
not countenance any United States dictum
and so the degree to which any body can
really challenge
what are profoundly unjust policies any
body like that are you know I don't know
much about it but I can tell you that
they have been pretty cowardly on many
occasions now that the government's are
not in a position to say things like
that they don't that's not the language
that they use
you know regard of what stripe of
government but that's the language I
mean I have to latitude to use that and
I've found them cowardly and
unwillingness to speak clearly about
what they see going on you know
pan-american Health Organization is an
apolitical organization that's a hundred
years old
twice as old as the World Health
Organization and when the head of the
Pan American Health Organization sure
George
aleem went to Haiti recently he said
this is nuts I mean since we're on radio
I'm supposed to say that's a
paraphrasing that means you know Sir
George probably didn't say this is nuts
but my friends an international public
health say this is you know this is
really awful to an embargo against the
the country that is least able to really
resist that is it makes no sense and and
yet I think international politicians
and diplomats are really now getting
very divorced from clear and
straightforward language that says this
is right this is wrong it's a and so
what about the UN I guess my big
question is when the United States
contradicts u.s. foreign policy what
happened
I think we have a you know a lot of
information about that well I'm sure
this will be very cheerful now that
there's a history and it's very clear in
fact it's official I'll just quote an
official source okay so I don't have to
make it up the I mentioned that in 1986
the World Court
highest judicial body condemned the
United States for international
terrorism for the unlawful use of force
ordered it to terminate its atrocities
and to pay substantial reparations to
the victim namely Nicaragua the u.s.
responded by immediately escalating the
war bipartisan incidentally the the
judgment was dismissed with contempt
it's disappeared from history
Nicaragua went to the Security Council
which debated a resolution not
mentioning anyone but calling on all
states to observe international law it
was vetoed by the United States Britain
which is a attack dog not a country
anymore agreed they helped out by
abstaining the meant to the general
assembly same result no it's out of
history doesn't exist I mean we've had
just how many reams of paper have been
devoted to the war on terrorism in the
last several months try finding one
reference to the fact that the leader of
the war on terrorism happens to be the
only state in the world which has been
condemned by the highest international
authorities for international terrorism
and responded by escalating the terror
well you know the legal adviser of the
State Department Abraham so fair
explained you can read it in the State
Department bulletins why the US was
rejecting the World Court jurisdiction
and even wait for the judgment because
they know it was going to be they
rejected the jurisdiction when the case
was brought and he explained and he's
right he said in the early days of the
United Nations everybody voted our way
he didn't explain why but it's obvious
you take a look at what was the world
was like and the late forties in the
early 50s and you if you didn't vote the
way the United States said you were in
very deep trouble
so everybody voted our way and it was
nice
then came decolonization you know and
the membership of the United Nations
became much more diversified it fell
under what's called the tyranny of the
majority otherwise known as democracy
and I mean and the other you know other
even the industrial world began to
recover from the war and the world has
gotten more diverse and he what he said
is by now we can no longer count on
other he said other nations the world
just don't agree with us and often vote
against us in the United Nations
therefore or anywhere else World Court
therefore we must reserve to ourselves
the right to determine what falls within
the domestic jurisdiction of the United
States in this case what fell within the
domestic jurisdiction of the United
States was a terrorist attack on
Nicaragua and there and that's correct
now nobody would be so impolite as to
quote this in public it's been on a
public record for 17 years you can judge
how often it's been quoted but he's
correct in other words you do if you do
what we say fine then we like the
international institutions if you happen
to cross us you know get lost we have
the guns and we'll do what we feel like
in fact if you take a look at the when
you read about the United Nations what
you hear is you know tyranny of the
Russian veto nothing can ever happen now
that was true for a couple of years in
the late forties in the early 50s when
it was totally under the lash of the
United States as the wall street
journal' put it at the time yeah then it
was used as an instrument
the Russians and they voted against you
know against they vetoed resolutions in
fact I was student in those days
graduate student and you're a profession
you mind if I don't blame your leading
anthropologists you know famous
anthropologists I mean me those guys
they developed they worked on this
question of why the Russians were always
so negative you know they kept saying no
and they developed a theory which was
taken quite seriously I mean there may
be three people in Cambridge who thought
it was a joke we used to call it diaper
ology the theory was that the Russians
were raised with swaddling clothes and
that makes them negative but the United
Nations and that was taken very
seriously
he read it okay well and that's what it
was like in the late 40s in the early
50s and then as I say came
decolonization you know this changes
since the 1960s the US was far in the
lead and vetoing Security Council
resolution and just about everything
every topic second is Britain a very
distant third is France I'm hurting
anthropological investigation resisted
why Americans are so negative you know
the British only slightly less negative
well you know that's that's how the
United Nations works now on sometimes it
very often in fact it does vote against
the United States hasn't been Haiti but
take the Cuban embargo that's been
condemned by everybody you know it comes
up over and over again it doesn't come
up in the Security Council because the
US will veto it but comes up in the
General Assembly all the time the votes
are unanimous they're two votes against
Israel is compelled to vote with the
United States has no choice so there's
two votes against but Israel violates
the embargo I mean they you know they
know they got a vote with the boss but
they violate the bar
the OAS which is you say is totally
supine they've condemned that their
legal commissioners condemned that it's
been condemned as in violation of
international law the European Union
brought it up the World Trade
Organization because the embargo
especially the secondary boycott parts
are in gross violation of the World
Trade Organization rules they brought it
up the Clinton administration to
responded first by saying that the you
know there's a thing in the world trade
organization called the national
security exemption like if your
existence is at stake you know you can
violate a trade law so the u.s. first
claimed the national security you know
like if we don't start let's prevent
food and medicine from going to Cubans
will disappear it was a country but that
was too ludicrous so they finally simply
told them you know the usual answer get
lost
I mean I don't care what it says and
there's rules anymore than we do when it
says that you can't stop the Japanese
from sending supercomputers which are
better than ones made here you don't
like it do something about it as Stalin
once is reputed to have said when the
Vatican criticized him how many
divisions has the Pope you know I don't
know if he said that or not but that's
what the powerful say you know you you
don't like what we're doing I do
something about it
and there's nothing anyone can do except
us we can do it you know if there
changes internally in the United States
you know anything can happen
one of the reasons why this stuff is
never reported and it isn't and never
discussed is because people might find
out about it if we had a functioning
democracy here you know you might find
out that what's being done in your name
like it and this goes all over the world
I said I was in Turkey a couple days ago
what we've done there and under the
Clinton years is grotesque I mean the
charges against Russia [ __ ] in The
Hague
bad enough but nothing like what happens
in the same years that Clinton was
paying for just in Turkey alone that's
one place therefore it isn't discussed
the Cuban the votes on the Cuban the UN
votes on the Cuban embargo you know they
scarcely mentioned the vetoes are almost
never mentioned I mean the most recent
one finishes December was less December
December 15 the Bush was making speeches
about how the terrible Palestinians are
enhancing terror well there's a way to
reduce terror which overwhelmingly is
powerful people of course the US and
Israel there's a way to do it you
couldn't implement the u.s. Mitchell
report and send international monitors
to observe to who do in fact to reduce
violence when they're there it came up
the United Nations Security Council the
Europeans introduced a resolution to
that effect calling for reduction of
violence and implementing the Mitchell
report sending international monitors
u.s. vetoed went to the General Assembly
overwhelming vote in favor this time the
United States also picked up not only
Israel which is automatic but also now
rue
the one of the other Pacific Islands and
I think jointly they have 20,000 people
so it wasn't totally isolated the way it
usually is you think there was any
report about this take a look you know
if you really search you could find
that's why it works
I told you he would know okay we have a
question back there the gentleman in the
orange t-shirt did you hear the question
how how is the ecological crisis in
rural Haiti affected human development
and you know it there's a there's a
short answer in a long answer I'll go
for the short one in it and it's been
the impact has been profound I mentioned
already the struggle for food wood and
water and the fact that you know people
don't have electricity and or you know
you know or say gas you know because in
some kinds of Cubans for example trying
to help Haiti develop and a way of
cooking with small little propane type
things that are really small and wood
would match the way it's been done in
terms of scale I mean there's these are
not places with stoves these are places
where food is cooked outside and it as
the Haitians say soot wash soot on three
stones so the there have there's really
no way to do that without replacing you
know wood as a fuel coal charcoal as a
fuel and and I and again I just don't
think that's going to happen without
some systematic approach to developing
some alternative because in the absence
of an alternative that's promoted by a
policy there's really you know there's
no what no one has capital to go and buy
such a thing or to replace the the
propane you know or its solar stuff
hasn't worked very well but the the
ecological crisis from deforestation
alone
not talking about pollution of
groundwater has just been profound and
terrible and again I don't think there
have been USAID have funded tens of
millions of dollars for reforestation
projects and they obviously have not
been successful I do remember that USAID
once funded a single drainage project in
port-au-prince about five different
times under the do value is the same
drainage project that never got done now
thank god they're gonna try to really
clamp down and make sure that area seats
government uses funds wisely but I don't
I think those giant reforestation
projects maybe someone here knows more
about it than I do none of them has been
really success by internal government
Accounting Office reviews and again
that's another tip from the gnome stir
as we say this is something Radio sorry
another tip from professor Chomsky go to
official sources and you know the
Government Accounting Office has has
published its own internal report on the
performance of its of its our aid wing
it's really devastating and you know I
recommend if you look at that as well
because there's been projects in the
past which have been tried and failed my
own view as to why they failed well they
were being routed through a government
really did not have the health and
welfare of the Haitian people at heart
meaning the family dictatorship followed
by the military which is now again that
may sound fantastic as a theory to some
people but it seems I believe it makes
sense thank you yes this question is for
dr. former how is the let's talk about
AIDS in Haiti and the coalition to the
rest of southern Africa where are you
I'm here and also 1981 the NIH started
with 4-h and Haiti was yeah well I mean
it's really a very disturbing chapter of
us Haitian relations I didn't mention it
here but you're right I think it's worth
mentioning that and some people here are
old enough to remember that back in the
early 80s as you were saying the
suggestion was widely circulated in the
US press that HIV had come
or at that point aids because we hadn't
really identified HIV had come to the
United States from Haiti and of course
just the opposite was true as is the
case I'm learning with most reporting
and that HIV actually went to Haiti from
the United States and and to all the
countries of the circum Caribbean Basin
the same way except Cuba he was the only
country that didn't have that that tight
relationship and the countries were the
closest relationships to the United
States and the most dependent on the
kind of aid and expertise that we've
talked about already were the countries
most affected with Haiti actually being
the country most dependent on US exports
so not to make a crude ecological
Association but HIV actually came to
Haiti from the United States and then
spread because of poverty gender
inequality and political violence which
made any kind of again public health
approach very difficult I mean I worked
during those years in Haiti and in 1992
for example or 93 perhaps a women's
group that I had worked with for some
time working on a video about gender
inequality and HIV the women's group was
showing the video in a village not far
from our clinic and they were planning
to lead a discussion afterwards and and
soldiers came and dislodged them from
the building and threatened them of
their lives and actually with the head
of the women's group said to me you know
I don't think we should do this anymore
AIDS prevention she said it's just too
dangerous that was you know that was
1993 and so you know I read about and
someone I'm sure is gonna have a very
different take on this than I do but
reading about this horrible persecution
of the Haitian press alleged to be going
on now is just amazing to me when in
fact we have documentation of a of a
massive and radication of the
independent press and Haiti under the
Duvalier sand under under the the
military regime and if there is a great
deal mixing things together but the the
very most difficult time for doing work
like that HIV prevention
it was during the 80s and 90s actually
particularly the late 80s and early 90s
so the epidemic in Haiti is moving
forward untrammeled by really
significant prevention efforts and
that's part of what is being proposed by
the Ministry of Health a robust HIV
program let me just tell you this one
thing
the World Bank and other funders got
together and started putting together
this aids package for the Caribbean an
aid package and the one country most
affected by HIV in the Caribbean was got
you know was slated for zero dollars
that's that's how and these are these
are professionals these are doctors and
public health experts who are saying oh
well it's okay that we don't have haiti
the most affected country in in the
region involved in our funding program
so i blame my own colleagues for for not
questioning that I just went to a
meeting in Jamaica two days ago by the
way never go to Jamaica for one day stay
longer I went to a meeting of the Pan
American Health Organization for one day
and and the the most affected country
was not represented there's 25 countries
represented there but not Haiti so I
mean that this is this is how this is
how it plays out in terms of specific
health problems I thank you for asking
the question okay um what what is the
what is the purported rationale for the
current US embargo I mean we beat that
the presentations began with an
introduction but so far I haven't heard
the ex what the purported explanation of
the current US embargo is what our it's
a you know publicly stated goals
what is its hidden agenda if any and in
a larger sense what are the policies
that the United States and the IMF or
any other relevant entities what are the
policies that those entities want the
government of Haiti to be adopting and
what are conversely what are the
policies that the current government
is attempting to adopt instead of
whatever the United States and other
entities would prefer to impose well I'm
gonna will do this in a two-part thing
because I know I know no one will have
things to add but I'll just say that I
believe in fact that many people in
those institutions are opposed to the
embargo because I've spoken with them
directly I went to the to someone to
talk to some of these people and you
know and again mower is a concerned
citizen because our own group does not
depend upon this kind of aid and it's
not a commodity in a concerned American
citizen the US citizen our group doesn't
rely on any of these efforts to run our
hospital we rely on private donations
from you know friends and funders and
some progressive foundations and
churches well this is nothing to do with
us but I did go there because they're
not that many US citizens who are saying
wait this is this is unacceptable
and I met person after person who said
oh we're so embarrassed by this you know
this is a ridiculous policy so then you
keep asking where is this coming from
then if you're embarrassed by it you
know you are the vice president and then
fill in the blank you know
choose your favorite organ I went to
several of them and I already told you
what the head of the pan-american Health
Organization said you know regarding the
fact that we can't have an embargo on
you know country where there's so many
public health problems and so you asked
where is this coming from and I'm
getting a normal have gotten to this you
know from the other way just by knowing
the the information but I finally came
to believe in any case that this is
actually coming from the State
Department under the suggestions of just
a probably a fairly small number of
people Jesse Helms is one of them I'm
quite sure no I'm serious I mean and I
thought well you know you can't you know
a huge government like this a huge you
know the hugest government you mean
can't have its policy determined really
by one person of course that's been a
point of institutional analysis is
that's not how it works
but Haiti is so beaten down right now
that you know you wonder again if
someone was almost like a grudge of
course it makes better
sense to not think of it that way but
right now there's a lot of I told you
about talking to someone today on the
phone who said you know I find this
embarrassing and I'd like to see it
reversed so that gets me to just one
little point that I'll pass it over to
no I don't think there's any anything
that the Haitian government can do to
please the people who are behind this I
don't think there's any way there
because the things that have been asked
for as concessions have all been made
already by the Haitian government so I
just don't think there's no way they
could they can't win they could never do
anything to meet the demands of the
people who are the architects the
intellectual architects of the embargo
and I'm gonna go ahead and quote Jeffrey
Sachs who said a couple days ago it
seems to me that there are only two
possibilities one that the the goal of
this policy is to overthrow the
democratically elected government of
Haiti or be that there's such massive
incompetence inside the machinery of
state up here that they're just bad at
executing another policy so it's either
that's their policy or they're
incompetent those are the two options
that he could see no well just to add
the leading individual who's
spearheading this happens to be Colin
Powell he is regarded as the
administration dove you know the
moderate and which is probably true what
that means he's slightly to the moderate
side of Attila the Hun but for example
it was just a meeting of Carrick on you
know the Caribbean and I forget what it
stands for the Caribbean countries
everyone was opposed to the embargo
every single one how I'll insisted that
we're going to continue that's our
policy so and Helms is behind it too
you're right but you know they don't
have to yield to the Helms on this they
they're doing it because they want to so
then you ask why well they have a
technical reason Haiti didn't meet our
elevated standards of how a democratic
election should be run and you know I
don't doubt that there were all kinds of
gelareh days in the election and maybe
this was wrong and that was wrong and
the other thing but to talk about our
standards for elections if you consider
the countries to which we which we don't
put under embargo I mean this doesn't
even you know it's it's it's hard to
imagine that people can even know these
words without you know such
embarrassment that it's almost
indescribable so that can't be the
reason what the real reason is I suppose
is what it's been all along I mean they
have said the reason that they hated our
state from the beginning very beginning
you know he was a renegade and a radical
and a firebrand and preaching class
warfare and the other thing a psychotic
you know everybody charges against we're
incredible was because his government
and the official terminology was it
wasn't sufficiently diverse it only
included the 90% of the population who
live in the slums and the hills and it
didn't include what the United States
defines as Haitian civil civil civil
society namely the private sector
national and international so it didn't
give sufficient representation to the
meaning dominance to US investors who
are Haitian civil society and to you
know the navs family and the grant
family and the other small families were
they you know the current version of the
guys who were calling for slavery 200
years ago didn't give them dominance so
therefore it's not sufficiently broad on
the other hand if some government you
know like just about everyone excludes
virtually the entire population but
gives privilege to those who really
count you know the private sector
National Indian and international into
fine there's no problem I mean that's
been said officially so many times that
you can hardly even call it a hidden
agenda you know it's it's an open agenda
and it's an understandable one nobody's
gonna say it and you know if they
actually say it in almost these words
the gentleman in the back can help when
we can get the 22 did everyone hear the
question the discussion of cuban
assistance to haiti in the form of
medical personnel how how is this gonna
work in in if if there's you know aid to
resuscitate haitian public health is
blocked
i think it's a great question and first
let me tell you i admire those
physicians enormous lee and in fact some
of them have pitched in in our work and
they've done really valiant they've
really they're really working hard and
there's almost 800 there I think now so
there are more Cuban doctors in rural
Haiti than Haitian doctors there are
more Haitian psychiatrists in Montreal
than all of Haiti okay and and this is a
trend by the way when somebody studied
264 graduates of the medical school
under a period of a couple I don't
remember how many classes under
falsified do Gagne and there were only
four or left in Haiti so again this is a
long-standing problem lack of medical
personnel hey Cuba as you might know has
the largest number of doctors per
population in the world of any country
as far as I know so they're sending out
doctors has been great however I think
that the the weakness of the Cuban eight
strategy is nothing to do with them it's
like again yelling at countries because
they're poor is they you need a third
partner with capital either the Haitian
public health infrastructure needs an
infusion of capital right now in order
to make the make that work because the
problem frankly is that if you have
Cuban doctors fitting into the Haitian
health system that's terrible the
Haitian health system is all
fee-for-service exclusively so you just
what you do I don't you know you
probably know this because you're from
Haiti but if you're in a clinic
Haidee or hospital that the public
hospitals when the doctor prescribes
something he passes the he passes or she
passes the prescription to the patient
or the patient's family member and then
you go out of the hospital to the
pharmacy outside buy the medicines bring
them back give them to the nurse I'm
talking about gloves and intravenous
fluid too not just an medicines
so having cubans come in and fit into a
fee-for-service system when they've been
trained in a system of socialized
medicine where that's not done you know
as a major problem and it's a very
significant weakness of the program if
if we were the you know the obvious
partner for the Cuban aid program is us
we're the ones with neighbors with all
the money you know and in a sane world
of course if a group of countries were
trying to come together to help improve
public health and Haiti it would be a
wealthy country and a country with
enormous technical capacity in Health
which is Cuba helping out the the their
neighboring country and right now
there's still it's still not there's
still no strategy France Canada the
other countries that could do this have
not come through yet to be the third
partner
the people here the question how does
prevention especially preventive
invective Jesus infectious Jesus did I
say
and effect just diseases that's my field
I'm supposed to say that correctly
how does prevention figure in the plants
well one of the big problems is again is
that if you say to people you know kind
of like in the United States don't do
drugs you know don't get on welfare
whatever but you know your your your
what we what that happens too often in
these settings is you're exhorting
people to do things they cannot do you
know for example don't drink dirty water
well you know it's no water that's great
in Cambridge you know where you try not
to scoop water out of a puddle to drink
it when you're thirsty on Mass Ave or
you buy for no good reason no offence
Dinesh Poland Springs water our water is
clean there's nothing to do with
individual volition you know or some kid
at Cambridge Rindge and Latin High
School whether you know as long as as
they drink the public water they're not
going to get sick so I actually have
limited enthusiasm for prevention
preventive measures that rely
exclusively on exhortation when in fact
the big problems are structural problems
so prevent prevention of infectious
diseases like malaria you know it's very
difficult to do without money without
cleaning up stagnant water and that's
not the job of individual families you
know it's not the job it's the job of a
public health system
you know malaria typhoid you know you
have to have clean water and it's not
know I didn't have to develop clean
drinking water when I was in fifth grade
my parents didn't make me do that they I
actually never thought about it until
much later in life and that's again same
thing HIV sure we need to push education
we need to push prevention we need to
have culturally appropriate tools we did
all that in our in our work but their
impact on that epidemic if the major
cofactors are poverty and gender
inequality will be limited so we need
resources in order to have a public
infrastructure and then prevention and
education will really have its impact
but with with you know with no clean
water and no access to vaccines
you know exhorting poor people to you
know wash their hands and drink their
clean water not that you're saying that
I'm just saying
that's and the unfortunate let's what's
left over when you've really destroyed a
public health infrastructure okay
clearly there's no money in Haiti but
the fact remains that receipt has been
in power for a year and it's not very
evident what he's actually been doing
and I was wondering if you could if you
could comment on that and also what some
of the legitimate criticisms are of the
of the so-called opposition first of all
I'm not so sure what that means to be in
power I mean in in other places that
means having you know say over over
something there's the general concept of
power and I've already told you that the
Brigham Women's Hospital is larger than
the possible for the Republic of Haiti
for eight million people so I'm very
skeptical of analyses not that yours is
doing this but I'm saying I'm skeptical
of analyses that exaggerate the power
and the agency of people in these very
marginalized situations so I actually
don't think that the will of the Haitian
people has ever been respected they're
trying to get a government that
represents broad aspirations in power
but I don't think they've succeeded they
succeeded for a few months back in 1991
and then you could actually take a good
look you could just look at the record
and say well what happened during those
seven months how did it work but I'm not
sure that's ever happened since and so I
actually don't agree that we can see a
government in power a government in
power doesn't have to pay interest on
loans that's never received a government
and power does not have to have it's
it's it's you know legal rights approved
by someone like Jesse Helms you know so
I I don't I don't think that that that
government has been in power yet and the
reasons that I hope it comes into power
are really related only to the fact that
the Haitian people voted to have them in
power and I kind of think that that's a
legitimate legitimate aspiration for
people to want to have a democratic
regime so that's my take on it as
someone who's working there I I you know
when I inquire over specific projects as
I did with the health project which is
my job
I found that again they're not in power
they're there I know I heard they were
paying interest on a loan they haven't
received I thought it was a canard that
is just a
the you you were mentioning legitimate
op criticism of the opposite opposition
I think they're all legitimate I think
they're all correct that's my view I
think the opposition has no broad-based
support does not represent the
aspirations of the the majority does not
wish to come to power through democratic
elections in fact they said and many of
them the leaders of the opposition
movement said we know we can't win in a
democratic elections that that's what
they said publicly again this is in the
New York Times that great during paper
of record and so I find that the
criticisms I hear from the people with
whom I live the in rural Haiti are to be
very compelling in fact I haven't heard
a lot of uncompelled and criticism
criticisms of the opposition okay we're
going to take two more questions this
gentleman here and then that lady there
for me and my junior colleague given
that given their struggles internal
well I think there's a we can pose it as
a dilemma either it will come internal
to the population of the United States
or it won't come that's just the nature
of power mechanic and that's the same on
every other issue you know there happens
to be you know the United States happens
to have overwhelming power these things
are not brought to the attention of the
American population how many people in
the United States would know anything
about one word of what was said tonight
it's all public record but no but nobody
wouldn't know about it and there's a
reason for that the reason is that
political ideological economic managers
are terrified of the population they
don't want them to know and they make
efforts to prevent them from knowing on
all sorts of issues not just this way
you run through a long list and I think
they're right you know my suspicion is
that people in power are probably
correct in their assessment that if you
if the population does know what's being
done in their names they're not gonna
let it happen and we've seen example
after example of this when it was
possible to get around the centers of
power through a popular organization so
yes I think their their judgment is
probably accurate it's extremely
dangerous to let the public know what's
going on and therefore you have to
marginalize people and
you know direct them to something
consumerism or lie to them or whatever
because if they find out then I don't
like it
most people are decent human beings
they're not gonna want to know if they
learn that they're doing things that
Paul was talking about they're not gonna
let it happen and that's our job you
know and it's been done before it can be
done here yeah I don't have much to add
to that because I agree and you know
that's why ice why I'm here tonight is
because I I have I admire the Haitian
people more than any other I've ever met
and I don't have a long experience in
other settings but but I do have this
really deep almost aw of what they have
done over the last 200 10 years and what
they've resisted and survived and of
course many of them have not survived so
I've also have a deep sense of shame
that so many people have have died along
the way and at the same time I and this
gets back she's gone already
he's back to you a question oh she
didn't like my answer she split you know
this it's back to you know my response
to that question I don't think that in
spite of you know I would regard as
romantic notions that this is going to
be settled going to go to in Haiti by
Haitians and I know that's what you're
saying the same thing that's your point
and if it we're going to be settled in
Haiti by Haitians it was it would it's
already been clear on so many occasions
that this is not you know neither did
the the Haitians in Haiti are not the
primary architects of what we've
described it today and so I go back to
places like I thought you know I've
actually been to some of these places
these powerful bureaucracies you know
that and I think that displays I hope a
good deal of faith even that that you
know something decent or less punitive
could come out of those institutions but
I actually have a lot of faith in the
decency of most people in the belief
that if you could get this message out
to more people if you could have it less
hidden away or and have it more the
focus of popular discussion by non
experts who are not running the world it
would be here in this country I mean it
would be a wonderful thing for for poor
people in general and including the poor
people people living in poverty in Haiti
who are the majority and I know that's
what inspires him to to do work outside
of linguistics which I always found
impenetrable anyway but you know I mean
that's that that's why we're here the
stories and to see that and you know
really romanticize that each individual
Asian is gonna solve problems or the
oppressor empower or proceed to that
level is really something I find 1005
hurts because it is just Mother Earth is
not going to produce any more and it's
one time so my welfare in the United
States depends on you having less and
that's how it is so how I mean to what
extent do we really are we really being
realistic and expecting that be happy
when we graduate from these institutions
we've got work in the workers
you know if I buy Pfizer's you know
stock I wanted to do well I don't care
what happens out there so that's not the
realistic aspects of what shapes my life
and I the lack of education people so my
call and I'm asking this if you look at
from a global perspective what is a wall
of oppressed nations to get together and
really when you know because there's a
power in numbers to wait some sort of
progressive unity notions I mean you're
absolutely right there's there's a
what's called south-south cooperation
you know
cooperative interaction among the people
who are the most oppressed in the world
and by far the most numerous that can be
very valuable and but to try to develop
it is not easy for one thing in every
one of these countries including the
ones you mentioned there are elite
groups who basically dominate them whose
tie is to the West not to their local
populations they don't want south-south
cooperation in the interest of the
general population
I didn't hear where you're from but
allow it okay so you know that's the way
it is there and that's weighted
everywhere so south-south cooperation is
going to be people-to-people cooperation
and at that point it can also become
south and north cooperation actually one
of the important things really important
that's developed over the past couple of
years for the first time ever is
significant interaction among
populations south and north working on
the same pursuing the same goals and
interests so for example I was in Brazil
a couple of weeks ago at the porto
alegre meetings now there's around
70,000 people there and three times or
four times where the
for the world Social Forum and they're a
fairly good representation of
substantial parts of those probably
large majorities of the population in
many countries of the world now they
don't have the countries don't have the
right kind of interaction you know like
Brazil and India to you or South Africa
the three of them huge South countries
they don't have contact they don't know
about each other but at meetings like
porto alegre they do come together
farmers workers environmental activists
women's groups all sorts of people from
south and north and they have the same
interests you know some are rich some
are poor but basically have the same
interest as human beings and are working
together uncommon programs that's
extremely important in fact it's the it
that if there's gonna be any hope for
the future that's where otherwise
they're gonna have to change their own
country south and north I don't have
much side of that again except that you
know what I was thinking is you were
talking is that you mentioned oppressed
nations and you know it's it's really
more oppressed people because the the
elites of so many nations have really
sided against the poor in many case four
majorities and with the you know
colonial powers at one point or
post-colonial new colonial powers so you
know Haiti unfortunately is a very
classic example of a Latin American
nation that within short within a small
number of a small amount of time really
its elite align itself so wholly with
the foreign powers that you know they
were the biggest sources of you know
negative commentary about the poor you
know if you read the literature from
19th century Haiti and early 20th
century Haiti from the elites who you
know writing in French there their views
of the Haitian people the people that
who I serve as a position are are as bad
and racist as
some of those from North America and
where they were echoed by the way and so
I don't have a lot of experience working
with elites in fact I have none I would
just confess right here in Haiti I have
none and the professionals who I meet in
minute you know especially physicians
minute ministries Minister of Health are
really pretty decent people in my
experience and they're not so likely to
speak that way about the people who we
serve as the you know intellectuals that
I read read it when I was in graduate
school the Haitian intellectuals so that
gives me that that process has actually
given me I hope not undue optimism that
there are people in all different layers
of these societies who want to see the
right thing done okay well I think our
time has come up and I want to thank
professor Chomsky and dr. farmer and
particularly
I also want to thank the Western
Hemisphere project and all the other
co-sponsoring MIT organizations in the
person of Dan Ashe to have worked very
hard to make this evening possible and
bring a historical perspective and a
compelling approach to the analysis of
the Haitian situation thank you
[Applause]